the movie starts in a university lab
where a student named devin is playing a
strange frequency-like sound on his
computer the sound is like that of a
distorted radio but in a very eerie way
meanwhile the lab in charge professor
richard enters the room and questions
devon about what he's doing devon
reveals that he picked up the frequency
from another galaxy and suggests that
they do further research on it he even
claims that the sound has a repetitive
pattern which is very soothing to hear
however the professor cannot hear any
patterns and he tells devin to switch
off the sound he also tells the boy to
focus on other work rather than wasting
his time on unnecessary stuff which has
no educational value at all expectedly
devin is upset as he was hoping that the
professor would help him despite this he
decides to continue his research and
leaves the lab with a cassette
containing the strange sound later when
he reaches home he is caught off guard
as his teen sister joyce and her
boyfriend vic are making out devon
immediately orders the two to put on
some clothes before walking away next he
reaches his room and starts examining
the strange frequency once again in
hopes of finding some clues just then
joyce approaches him and makes him
promise that he won't reveal about the
earlier incident to their dad devin
loves his sister very much so he agrees
without hesitation he then tells her to
focus on her studies and stay away from
trouble because if dad finds out about
it she will be grounded saying this much
he puts his computer in sleep mode and
goes to bed shortly after joyce snoops
around his work desk and decides to go
through his stuff she also puts on his
headphones and as soon as she turns on
the computer it starts playing the
strange sound surprisingly joyce is
taken over by the sound and she begins
experiencing an immense sense of
pleasure some strange waves also go
through her fingers implying that there
is something magical about the frequency
in the next scene we are introduced to
dr emery who is a renowned surgeon in
the city he is also the father and only
parent of devon and joyce after a long
night shift at the hospital he returns
home to find joyce still hypnotized by
the strange frequency it appears that
she listened to the sound the whole
night angry dr emery scolds his daughter
and asks her if she took any narcotics
but the latter calmly replies that she
was just listening to music she also
suggests that he listen to the music but
when dr emery checks her pulse he
notices that it is dropped significantly
before he can take any action joyce gets
up and leaves for school she also takes
the strange cassette along with her
after a while devin wakes up and starts
chatting with his father when he finds
out that joyce has taken his cassette he
immediately rushes outside to stop her
but is too late meanwhile joyce is
heading to school in her boyfriend's
minivan as vic is driving joyce suddenly
plays the cassette just like before she
is hypnotized by the sound and strangely
vic also enjoys it the two then discuss
the sound saying it's the most soothing
music they've ever heard they then
decide to share the music with their
friends so that they can also experience
the same euphoria after a while joyce
and vic reach school where devin is
already waiting for them he demands his
cassette back but the hypnotized duo is
hesitant to return it instead they try
to make devin understand that the sound
is a form of music which will make one
calm and happy devin who is an
intelligent science student immediately
refutes their claim and tries to take
his cassette back but vic pushes him to
the ground and asks him to stay away
seeing the commotion some other students
start gathering around the place and
devin is forced to leave after this he
heads to his lab where professor richard
is busy with his research on the rising
solar radiations however devon pays
little attention to it and heads home
with another copy of the frequency back
at the school several students have
joined joyce and vic and together they
are listening to the strange sound they
appear to be hypnotized by the sound
that they all refer to as music just
then the school principal who is for
some reason unaffected by the sound
enters the minivan and stops the music
he then orders the students to get back
to their classrooms but they refuse
instead they get inside the minivan and
drive away saying that they'll listen to
their music somewhere else meanwhile
devin video calls his japanese scientist
friend kelly and asks her to examine the
strange sound after he hangs up the call
dr emery enters the room and inquires
about joyce's strange behavior as of
late devon appears to be confused too
but he reveals that joyce has been
listening to the strange frequency which
appears to be some kind of music he then
tries to explain the same to his dad but
the old man thinks that his children are
messing around before going to sleep he
hands his car keys to devin and asks him
to go look for joyce later that night
devon enters a nightclub where the
students from before are partying with
the same frequency blasting in the
background even a dj is present there to
add effects to the already disturbing
sound as devin examines the place he
notices that several of the students
have been afflicted with a strange skin
disease they seem to have golden lesions
on their face devin quickly rushes to
joyce to find that even she has been
infected he tries to take her away but
joyce doesn't want to go she mentions
that the music is giving her energy a
kind that she has lacked her entire life
with no options left devon heads up to
skrillex and turns off the music as soon
as he does so all the students start
screaming in a state of panic as if they
are being tortured because of this devin
heads to a nearby telephone booth and
calls for help in the next scene we are
taken to the hospital where dr emery is
examining his daughter by this time her
condition is degraded even more devin
talks to his dad about the diagnosis and
dr emery reveals that joyce has an
unusually large amount of metal inside
her blood he also reveals that 72 other
students are also experiencing the same
symptoms the next day they again examine
joyce and find that her irises are
changing worried dr emery realizes that
something is wrong and immediately calls
the center of disease control a while
later the head of the cdc dr riddle
reaches the hospital and examines joyce
she then informs the father-son duo that
joyce is suffering from a rare disease
which affects the pituitary glands she
suspects that the students might have
taken some sort of ecstasy but devin
denies it he then shows her the strange
cassette and mentions that all the
students became infected after listening
to it as expected dr riddle laughs at
the theory as the disease cannot
transmit via sound dr emery also
supports her but devin requests that
they at least check on kelly who also
has a copy of the frequency if she is
found to be infected his theory will be
proved although confused dr riddle
agrees to contact the authorities in
japan later devon heads inside the
quarantine zone where all the infected
students are being kept they have become
extremely weak and some are on the verge
of death then he visits joyce who is
also in a lot of pain she requests that
he play the music as it will cure her
but devon refuses he then walks away but
not before promising his sister that she
will be fine at home devon watches the
news and again learns that the solar
radiations are reaching dangerously
extreme levels tired of all the negative
news around him he shuts down his
computer and goes to sleep when he wakes
up he finds his dad along with several
military soldiers in the house the
soldiers are there to confiscate all his
equipment as it has been proven that the
frequency is indeed causing the children
to become sick confused devin asks his
father about what's happening to which
the latter replies that there has been a
similar virus outbreak in naga japan the
same city where kelly is residing he
also reveals that the japanese prime
minister has declared the disease as a
pandemic hearing this devin is taken
aback and he starts blaming himself for
the entire incident which he probably
should it's his fault after all just
when he thinks that things can't get any
worse he notices that his hands have
also started getting infected later that
day the united states also declares a
state of emergency and a meeting is held
at the white house among the attendees
are devin dr emery and some other
important people dr emery mentions that
the disease is spreading at a rapid rate
but for some reason most of the infected
are teenagers people from the age group
of 20 to 24 are slightly infected
whereas those above 24 are totally
immune this is why devin was affected
very late as he is now 23 years old as
the group continues discussing the head
of the us military rises from his seat
and declares that the frequency is sent
by the aliens as an act of war the next
day devin and dr emery returned to the
hospital where joyce is still kept in
isolation her symptoms have worsened and
she can barely speak with time running
out the father-son duo decides to test
out a newly devised frequency which
apparently reverses the effects of the
alien frequency joyce continuously begs
her father to play her favorite music
claiming that it is the only thing that
can heal her but dr emery refuses after
a while a nurse brings out a cassette
player and plays the high-pitched sound
this badly hurts joyce and after a while
she passes out her heart also stops
working sending dr emery into a state of
panic he tries performing all sorts of
medical procedures to revive her but it
all goes in vain just then devin comes
up with an idea he rushes to a
prohibited section of the hospital and
retrieves the cassette he then returns
to joyce and plays the strange frequency
and surprisingly she comes back to life
joyce mentions that she is now ready to
face it stunned dr emory inquires about
what she's talking about but joyce
remains silent witnessing all this devin
becomes curious and begins researching
the source of the sound the next morning
he meets his dad and doctor riddle at
the hospital and shares a groundbreaking
discovery he reveals that the frequency
is not a disease but in fact a cure
devin supports his claim by mentioning
that the only students who have died of
the disease are the ones that the
hospital tried to cure he also brings up
the incident where joyce mentions that
she was ready unsurprisingly the doctors
are confused by the theories but devin
summarizes that the frequency is trying
to adapt them to the harmful solar
radiations he then shows a bunch of
plants that he experimented on last
night he exposed them to high amounts of
radiation but the only ones that were
able to survive were the ones that were
blasted with the same frequency
following this he takes the doctors to
professor richard's lab where they
verify that the sun is actually emitting
extremely harmful levels of radiation in
fact in just a matter of months the
whole world will perish if they don't
adapt to the radiation professor richard
researches a bit further and finds out
that the frequency came from a distant
planet which is 10 light years away from
earth the planet already experienced the
same levels of radiation which ravaged
their entire population with this
information devin concludes that the
aliens from that planet sent the
frequency to earth so that they could
save the humans in the next scene
another meeting is held in the white
house and the representatives
unanimously decide to play the music to
the public they have also engineered a
new form of music which will affect
adults too in no time the entire world
is blasted with the frequency infecting
much of the population a few months
later we are shown that joyce has fully
turned into an alien one which is
completely immune to the harmful
radiation devin also looks similar but
their dad dr emery has decided against
transforming as he wants to die in a
natural way and meet his wife in heaven
he mentions that he is willing to live
his entire life inside his home as he is
bored of working anyways the movie again
fast forwards by a month and this time
the harmful radiations have taken over
the world the movie ends as joyce and
her friends venture outside and enjoy
their time while dr emery looks at them
through the window
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching